all right let's keep converting
cartesian functions to polar coordinates
so the next one i have here is 3y
minus
7x
is equal to 10. and i i cut and pasted
our tool kit here and let's see what we
can do we want to convert this to a
function of r and theta so see the
simplest thing we have a y and an x well
we could just substitute we have we know
that y is equal to r sine of theta and x
is equal to r cosine of theta so let's
just substitute so three times y well y
is the same thing as r
sine of theta
minus 7 times x well that's 7
times r cosine theta
is equal to 10. remember these just came
from sohcahtoa nothing fancier than that
let's see if we can simplify this or
write it explicitly in terms of theta
let's see so we could factor out an r so
you get r
times 3
sine
theta
minus 7 cosine theta right we just
factor out an r is equal to 10 and now
divide both sides by this big expression
and you're left with r is equal to 10
3 sine of theta 10 divided by 3 sine of
theta minus 7
cosine
of theta
and we could also write this you know we
could say well this is r as a function
of theta we could write r of theta
right r is a function of theta i just
felt like doing that so you can show
that the function notation even works in
polar coordinates let's do another one
let me cut and paste our tool kit
look at that
all right
next one
so it says
y
is equal to 2x minus 3. well we can do
the same thing we know what y and x are
in terms of r and theta y is equal to r
sine of theta so let's write that r sine
of theta
is equal to two times x well x is our
cosine of theta our cosine of theta
minus three and let's see if we could
separate the r's and theta so let's
subtract this from both sides so we get
r
sine
of theta minus two r cosine of theta is
equal to minus three
just like the last problem we can factor
in r out so we get r times
sine
of theta
minus 2 cosine
of theta is equal to minus 3. now divide
both sides by this expression so you're
left with r is equal to minus 3
divided by
sine of theta
minus 2
cosine of theta there you go
all right now they want us to do some
problems
let me
clear everything
and i want to do some problems we're
going to convert the other way let's
write our tool kit down
it's proved to be useful
all right now they want us to convert
from polar to cartesian coordinates and
so they give us the polar function
r
is equal to 4
sine of theta so how do we convert this
into a function of x and y
so let's see here there's no obvious
there's no obvious
let's think about it a little bit
so we know we have this equation y is
equal to r sine of theta so can we write
sine of theta well we could just let me
do a little side here so y is equal to r
sine of theta
if we divide both sides by r what do we
get we get y
over r is equal to sine of theta
right well that seems to be helpful we
have a sine of theta there and then we
have something that at least it gets rid
of the theta out of the equation we're
still left with an r but it makes it a
lot easier to look at so let's do that
sine of theta is equal to y over r so
let's substitute that there so we get r
is equal to four times sine of theta
which is y over r so four
y over r
we could multiply both sides of this
equation by r and you're left with
r squared is equal to 4y
and we know what r squared is equal to
that tells us right there r squared is
equal to x squared plus y squared so you
get x squared plus y squared is equal to
y and there we have it we have it at
least in an implicit form we don't have
an exponent explicit equation but i
think that's good enough for now so you
see it's really just a lot of algebra
and a little i guess a little bit of
trigonometry but really a lot of algebra
are just kind of figuring out how to use
this toolkit let's do a couple more
so let's say
let me paste
the toolkit
let's say that we have the polar
coordinates
r
is equal to sine of theta
plus cosine of theta and just so you
don't lose the big picture of what we're
doing you know this is if we we could
graph this you could put your graphing
calculator on the polar coordinates and
i'll do future videos where we do graph
it and it'll produce some graph as theta
changes as we go around the circle the
radius will change it'll produce
something i don't know what it might
look like like flower petals or
something i don't know i'll have to i
don't have the intuition of exactly what
this will look like but what we're
saying is when we convert to x and y is
if you actually graphed it in cartesian
coordinates it would look the exact same
way that's all we're doing how do you
express the same relationship in terms
of x and y's
so how do we do this well the last one
we can these two we can rewrite
we can divide both sides of these
equations by r and we can have this this
is the same thing as sine of theta
is equal to
y over r
right i just divide both sides by r and
this is the same thing as cosine of
theta
is equal to
x over r just divided both sides of this
equation by r and you get this
so now we can use this to substitute
back here so r
is equal to sine of theta well we know
that's equal to y over r so it's equal
to y over r plus cosine of theta well
cosine of theta is equal to x over r
x over r and now we can multiply both
sides of this equation by r and we're
left with r squared is equal to y plus x
and we know what r squared is now that
should be second nature hopefully
so it's x squared plus y squared right
that's r squared
is equal to x sorry is equal to y plus x
there you go
let's do one more
one more let's do it without our tool
kit and i'll do it in a different color
so let's say we had
r
is equal to a squared so they're leaving
it abstract but a is some constant so we
hopefully know our intuition from a
couple of videos ago that this should be
a circle right if a was 3 then we'd say
oh r is equal to
9 right 3 squared and then just be a
circle with a constant radius of 9. so
how would you write this as a
as a
as in cartesian coordinates well we know
that x squared
plus y squared is equal to r squared so
one thing we could do maybe just square
both sides of this equation so you get r
squared is equal to what's a squared
squared well it's a to the fourth right
it's ace times a to the two times two so
a to the fourth and we know what x r
squared is it's x squared plus y squared
so you get x squared
plus y squared is equal to a to the
fourth
not too bad
and that's that's really i mean that'll
get you pretty far in converting between
cartesian and polar coordinates in the
next video we'll maybe explore a couple
of these graphs to hopefully give a
little intuition of of really how how
the relationships between r and theta
really works see in the next video